Belarusian president Alexander
lukashenka says the leader of Russia's
Wagner mercenary group has returned to
Russia suggesting he is in Saint
Petersburg now he also says the offered
to have Wagner Fighters stationed in his
country still stands if getting
pregosian had gone into Exile in Belarus
after his brief Mutiny in a deal agreed
with Russian President Vladimir Putin
as foreign
travel to Moscow or he might be
elsewhere but he's not on Belarus
territory
I think that Wagner will revolt and turn
their weapons against Belarus and its
authorities anything can happen in life
but I don't see such a situation
of Oliver is in Moscow on this Julia
tell us everything we know at this stage
on pregosian his whereabouts and the
status of Wagner Fighters as well
so the founder of the Wagner group has
returned from Belarus to Russia that's
according to president of Belarus
Alexander lucaschenkes who just heard he
said quote precursion isn't Saint
Petersburg but maybe he went to Moscow
in the morning so according to
lukashenko the fighters of the Wagner
group are in that permanent camps on the
territory of Russia and all the movement
of Wagner Fighters into Belarus depends
on their management and the Russian
authorities lukashenka also said that he
was absolutely not worried about a
number of Wagner Fighters stationed in
his country if Belarus needed to use
them they would be used instantly by the
country and that Belarus appreciated
that combat experience he also ruled out
a possibility that Wagner could turn its
weapons against Belarus he said that he
had spoken with evgeny progression on
the phone and discussed the further
actions of Wagner and its future and of
course he also assured that President
Putin did not intend to destroy or why
out as he said a precursion and
basically his shirt his plans to discuss
a pregosian at a forthcoming meeting
with the Russian president with
President Putin in interesting yesterday
July the 5th the fontanker and hisvestia
news outlets as well as the state of
Russia one TV channel showed footage of
a search in a mansion allegedly owned by
evgeny preggers he himself did not
comment on the search and so did the
ministry of internal affairs and other
law enforcement agencies the search took
place on June the 24th the very day of
the Wagner armed rebellion and during
the search some some weapons Cash Money
fake passports wigs and even a
helicopter were found all that including
numerous photographs of pregosian or the
changed appearance were presented by the
journalists so all that is very
significant as the world wants to know
the whereabouts of Russia's a former
warlord and who basically fulfilled
Russia's tasks abroad in in the
countries in in some African countries
in particular as well as he was involved
in the Ukrainian campaign of course and
in the fight for bahmoud and who
basically stands behind the armed
Rebellion here in Russia that took place
on almost two weeks ago hey Julia shop
of olive oil reporting from Moscow thank
you very much for that and I'm joined
Now by Pavel felgenhauer you are a
defense and Military analyst and joining
us on Skype from Moscow sir what do you
think is going on here with pregosian
apparently returning to Russia
uh well he didn't really go away from
Russia he made the brief visit to
Belarus and then returned so he's not an
exile there wasn't he supposed to stay
in Belarus wasn't that the deal
uh actual apparently not uh the the deal
was that he will move his base there
maybe in the future but immediately
right now not there's I would say a
ceasefire between Greg Ocean and the
Kremlin uh kind of freeze of the
situation that was agreed together with
a president of kashenka Belarus that's
and this is an uneasy ceasefire but both
sides are more or less holding it Prego
is traveling in Russia doing his
business and it was mentioned earlier
that there was money seized actually
sorry a quick pause because the the your
words your words strike me I find it
very interesting you say pregosian is in
Russia doing his business only a few
days ago his business involved turning
his thousands of armed men towards the
Kremlin why is Putin allowing this
what's your best explanation on that
well as I say it's a ceasefire between
the Kremlin and Craig ocean and his
Wagner group they retreated from
attacking Moscow but there's still a
viking credible force and apparently the
Kremlin is not ready to take them on
they are not on Russian territory
they're basically I mean there's a
legality there there on in the donbass
watch the International Community
considers Ukrainian territory but
they're in bases there right now in
camps and they're armed
will they be moved to Belarus ukashenka
does not know because this is a lot of
people and weapons the transfer would be
graders it's not easy to negotiate so
right now it's a kind of freezing of the
situation as it was on the 24th and very
importantly uh they did see is up to 10
billion rubles in cash that's about over
a hundred million dollars worth and it
was returned to precaution who said this
is money to pay his uh mercenaries what
sir what Wagner fighter is supposed to
give up their heavy Weaponry hand them
over to the Russian army
well there was talk about that it's not
where did that happen or not yet I think
that's going to be negotiable
I'm going to come to you with the same
point that I've been that I've really
been asking since the beginning I feel
there's a an enduring mystery around all
of this Putin has not allowed anyone or
anything to challenge his rule ever and
now there's a military commander who has
the Loyalty of thousands of well-trained
men who recently marched on Moscow in
any other situation this would be called
a rebel group and no State tolerates
Rebel groups unless they can't defeat
them so is that what you're telling us
that Putin essentially can't defeat them
so he has to make do with Wagner and
progosian
it was sort of I mean they're not ready
to take them on right now especially as
ukrainians are counter-attacking and
they're not the Kremlin is not ready to
take on Wagner there's keeping this
ceasefire negotiated by kashenka
um maybe would want these men to move to
his country and have his own mercenaries
and although there's a problem who's
going to pay them so but right now it's
a frozen situation the Mutiny was not
crushed it ended in a ceasefire in a
balanced situation by the way the the
idea of Wagner Fighters going to Belarus
there's another problem that lukashenka
himself just brought up and we we heard
him just before we came to you
um he it appears he was asked whether
they he was concerned that they might uh
rebel against
um Belarus and his answer seemed
flippant for a head of state he said
quote anything can happen in life I've
never seen a head of state take such a
casual approach to what would be a
critical matter of National Security
isn't doesn't that sound strange to you
well with this at least for Western
years it sounds strange well the Wagner
group is going uh something reminding me
of this Lance connect companies of the
50 16th century in Germany who could
hire themselves to different princes and
that was considered normal so that's
more or less how it is right now and
could maybe want to have such
mercenaries under to make his regime
more stable but he understands that
their royalty is not to him their
royalties do their own company all right
Pavel felgenhauer thank you very much
for your time today
thank you